welcome to this episode of the future
verse brought to you by Intelligence
Squared and Y tree I'm Kamal Ahmed
white tree was founded in 2017 to give
their clients insights and advice about
their money and life
tree calls this Insight Financial life
intelligence
at the heart of this idea of financial
life intelligence sits the vision of a
world where wealth is defined by how you
live not what you have
that's where the future verse comes in a
space to explore the conversations ideas
and insights that are driving change and
shaping our future
today we're returning to our current
theme in the future verse redefining
Legacy
last week's debate focused on the
question of whether individuals are
morally obligated to give much or all of
their wealth away this week we turn to
the how so you've decided you want to
make a charitable donation for example
but what is the most effective way to do
so I'm joined Now by two expert guests
to discuss this topic Anna Josh is the
founder and CEO of prism the gift fund a
charity which administers the giving of
individuals corporates foundations and
groups of donors making significant
gifts to Charities all over the world
she set up prism in 2005 with the aim of
getting more money into the charitable
sector and she's certainly done that
prisms donation income last year was a
hundred and fifteen million pounds
60 million pounds of which was donated
around the world David Duke is the
founder of street soccer Scotland a
non-profit social Enterprise that uses
football to help create positive change
in the lives of socially disadvantaged
adults and young people in 2001 David
became homeless following the death of
his father until a chance sighting of an
advertisement to join a football team
provided the momentum to turn his life
around
he was named the Sunday Times change
maker of the year in 2016 and was
awarded an MBE in 2018.
David and Anna thank you both so much
for joining me today and hello now we
brought to you together for this
conversation about giving because of
your differing and frankly complementary
experiences in the charity uh sector
Anna first off through your work as the
founder of prison you have advised
countless High net worth individuals and
being the facilitator of charitable
donations around the world across
multiple sectors
tell us a little bit first of all about
prism uh the gift fund I just wondered
2005 how why did you start and had you
done lots of research before that that
moment when you opened the doors yes so
in the 90s I
um set up and ran the British arm of an
American Israeli charity strength in
democracy in Israel and I learned a lot
from The Americans
and in America don't revised funds was a
very common method of giving in fact
today there's 175 billion dollars of
assets internalized funds in America
compared to 1.65 billion Sterling in the
UK so I saw those structures
um and I learned a lot all together
about fundraising for the Americans and
did about a year and a half's worth of
research
um I decided apart from a very large
government bureaucratic machine there
was nothing targeting the mid-upper end
of the market efficiently effectively
swiftly and set up prison the gift fund
and
like
lots of things it took time and effort
and energy building networking
um convincing people this was a good
method through which to give educating
not only doing a private client
intermediaries on what is a donor
revised fund which I'm still doing today
but over time more and more people
got to know about it and
bags law firms referred quiet and quiet
for a third client and it became a
snowball attack so David coming to you
tell us about the story behind your
charity
yeah well I was going to mentioned
earlier tomorrow you know I experienced
homelessness as a young person in
football was the kind of rope that
pulled my dark coal wheel being part of
a team you know finding some purpose and
some structure in a support network
um which led to a few years later
deciding you know having worked in a
charity so kind of moved out of
homelessness trained as a kind of
community worker worked with various you
know homelessness agencies and services
and continued modern football coaching
John there I just gave us this idea in
2009 that we would create Street Soccer
to allow people the same opportunity
which I had which was to be Again part
of a team you know we work with a lot of
people who are isolated and cut off from
society due to things that homelessness
and mental health addiction and so on
um and you know in order to take in the
create change people need to connect you
know when people need to be part of
something so the football allows people
back in a sense of belonging that
purpose that reason to wake up in the
morning and then once it involved
relationships about trust is built
between the coaches and support staff
and the players and then we start to
integrate Education and Training and
opportunities for people to move forward
largely done in partnership with a range
of other Charities who are all you know
trying to achieve similar goals so we
can bring it all together for the
greater good and David bring alive some
of the people that you've met and uh
supported on on their Journeys uh for
the people who are listening and
watching in to us today
yeah I mean you know
we meet so many inspiring people every
day you know and just seeing the courage
and the strength and you know that kind
of resilience that people have shown
just to kind of remain you know to be
here and then taking to get involved
because you know I think sometimes
people
see homelessness or addiction or you
know various
things out there is you know it's like
their own fault you know and it's like
there's not a lot of
okay the
NPC you know with with people because
they see them at their worst statement
what people sometimes don't see is you
know the journey that have been on you
know the fact that often people say oh
everyone deserves a second chance but
actually if you look at the Journey of
some of our players you know coming
through Care Systems and you know having
no support whatsoever you know it's
almost like a first chance they're
getting because actually they had no
chance of of getting that living I can't
a normal life based on the circumstances
but just in terms of you know we're
speaking about London there so one of
one of our new staff members in London
hey Frankie is uh came through one of
our Refugee projects so you know
you know was captured in Sudan managed
to escape the militants made his way
across the the border into Libya and
then over to Italy by boat
um you know very dangerous situation
even in the refugee camps in Italy and
you know he you know it was at risk of
the day just try to be fed and managed
to escape there and and threw down into
the the jungle and in Cali
um and then pibo arrived into into the
UK you know every stage young guy you
know talented young man but just because
of cultural differences and you know
things we don't even know about in in
today's press you know he's had to
escape and he's came to he came to the
UK arrived in London and he always knew
that if he could he or what he said was
if he knew if he found football then he
would find the community
and then he arrived at street soccer
um got involved
Captain Dirk in the England in the
homeless World Cup team
um and then came back and then started
helping get other refugees along and
getting them support so he became a
mentor when he kind of volunteer and he
just recently got status so he's not
allowed to work here in the UK so he's
now setting up new projects for street
soccer and using his own lived
experience taking that support others
you know in Easy that are remarkable
young man and uh and we're very honored
to have him on our team
it's that kind of Amazing Story isn't
Anna that that shows what can be done
with the the right approach to funding
and and support
um you gave us that incredibly Stark
figure about
um uh funding via Legacy extra Etc of uh
charities in the UK compared with the
levels of funding that could be
available or are available to charitable
sectors in the US
we'll see you here anna for the UK many
would say what you've revealed is
frankly not enough money goes into the
charitable sector
so
there are a number of issues going on
firstly
um
tax
so in America it's a much simpler
charitable tax break compared to the UK
I mean the UK have good tax breaks but
they're complex there's almost 750
million pounds every year unclaimed in
gift aid higher rate taxpayers
often don't do it smaller Charities
don't have the ability to claim so we've
got tax going on and then there's a sort
of psychology when you go to an American
University
you're pretty much tap for money by the
time you're a graduate
um you're an alumni so it took my
University of oh 20 to 30 years to
contact me to ask for some kind of
donation so we're not proactive we're
not as open and very sadly I'm afraid
and I speak to lots of fundraisers in a
charitable sector they're not very good
at Major donor fundraising and if you
look at the budgets of some of the very
large Charities raising 300 million 500
million about eight percent is from
major donors now when the government
um
was was was significantly funding
through Grant okay they were good at
government grants good at right mail but
now we need to rely on major donors much
more significantly
um so there's a question of educating
major donors how to fundraise educating
donors on the tax breaks
um and really
encouraging people to ask for money
prison the gift fund created a white
paper just before covid and Matt sended
a survey and one of the startling
results was everyone loved donations and
hated donors
so that's another psychology going on
here in the United Kingdom
David do you find that there's a sort of
British embarrassment
about
fundraising and almost and I think this
is
why really exploring
almost this idea that somehow as you say
Anna the fundraising bit is sort of
somehow unpleasant and not to be spoken
about
I mean in my experience you know I think
I totally agree and I think you know the
kind of major gift donors and stuff like
that is in like major donors it's really
hard for for me as a charity founder you
know a lot of her income is kind of
traditionally you know grants and trusts
you know you're getting a lottery funds
and stuff like that and quite a lot of
our kind of smaller scale
fundraising Gala dinner events and you
know traditional or maybe corporate
sponsorship because we've got a sports
settlement we kind of find a nice
balance between
in the CSR and brand awareness because
we're quite visible we've got you know
70 odd projects scattered across
Scotland for example
but I think it's it's
my experience of working me you know
major donors is you know it's about
building a relationship you know so it's
I've always just kind of I'm terrible at
asking Anna that's like I think it's
because I'm the founder I feel like I'm
asking for myself because I'm the
founder but that's the thing David
it often a donor will say they never
asked me
you're not asking for you you're asking
for your brilliant charity
yeah and that's I mean you know get
ahead of fundraising in place and
handles very good that they ask
so I you know so I can
ask like the team to kind of work on
that so you know in my jobs maybe just
to get into influence and just the way
through you know kind of share a vision
but I think you know it's it's also
about how you get to people as well
because a lot of you know
those kind of labels that people operate
in there is that we're having on there
well I'm very fortunate I mean in
Scotland for example I've created
relationships with some of the major
donors here and some of the leading
entrepreneurs and stuff like that and
and that's our relationship which is
kind of just about one trust and
involved in a relationship to the point
where Sometimes they come to us and say
look we'd like to support we've seen
what you do we'd like to help you to
scale that because also you know
sometimes
major donors because you know a lot of
the wealth has been created from an
entrepreneurial
in the background you can then take that
into the philanthropy and see how they
can you know invest in a part of your
organization which allows it to unlock
XYZ and some of the information that you
said that on a resume and I can probably
get that and I can see why you haven't
an organizational yourself involved
taking the support Charities like us
taking the get to that level and and to
actually understand it as well I mean
you mentioned gifted as well
you know we we get a lot better than we
were five years ago but for the first
probably nine years of the charity we
never claimed gifted because we never
had the Insight or the infrastructure to
do so but but now that we've got a
fundraising department and you know
things set up we are now able to so for
example we had a Gallow event recently
there was a lot there's a few kind of
major donors who are gifted on the night
and we were able to claim gifted on top
of that so you know there were a 50 000
pound donation then becomes you know a
62 or whatever the number is you know
it's it's money it's set in there and
you said
750 million or unclaimed
and and that when we have to lock it
because you know I'm working and I said
they're just like we do get government
income as well
um and you know things like and I think
they're in Scotland where you'll get the
public a paid a public service pay
review
you know so they're they're having to
find a massive hole of a couple hundred
million and where does that set you know
where did they take that fee and largely
it comes back down to the subject on the
charity sector because it was less money
there so and you know arguably you know
our guys are probably someone was hard
working and underpaid staff as well so
we're having to be really creative in
terms of how we how we do that and I was
even on Monday I was at uh Scottish
government event making all the local
authorities and stuff like that and
they've talked about how can we
tackle jail poverty if I'm not getting
any increase in budget you know in one
of the questions which was actually
where where does the private sector set
in this you know where there's business
in corporate with a part and and you
know impacting on this video and yeah
they're worth individuals as well but
Anna yes come back in Anna sorry
yeah no look it's it's
you need to educate Society to have a
responsibility to give
and everyone has a responsibility to
give
um but some can give more now that in my
view that needs to begin a primary
school in terms of education and that
also needs to
to change so that
people don't just think whatever they
regard as a very rich or responsible no
we're all responsible and then you know
how do you encourage people to begin
that Journey
um
by visiting projects like yourself as
well you know sometimes
each of our donors it's a very very
different story very little aligns them
what's motivated them in the first place
and it could be Health it could be
personal but often it's seeing something
and what I always say also to a donor is
you will always gain more than you give
so
um it will it will open your light it
will make it so much more interesting
um by engaging with whatever predict it
is
um but it's a journey
and I also say to fundraisers
um they say well you know
uh how do I do it
you know can you almost like can I wave
a magic wand
and the money will come falling down
well I'm sure as you know David it's
hard rock
and it takes many years
to build those networks and
relationships and persuasion
um
and people give to people that's the
other thing
so
you know people will be giving to you
Dave because you persuaded them that
what you've created is is really
effective and and meaningful so just
kind of you know Anna said it's about
people when it's about those
relationships because actually
for me it's not about it's almost like
sharing a vision of Bear in terms of
this is what an organization is doing
this is how it's helped change people's
lives this is how it helps the community
and instead of getting the donor to to
buy into that you know that vision for
better
let's go through the practicalities and
how prism helps people uh on this
journey you've touched briefly on the
tax system take us through that bit
specifically first as you say in the UK
it is more complicated than for example
in the US but not impossible what are
the key uh things that High net worth
individuals
people who have access to wealth and
want to do
make a difference to the society they
live in how can they approach the tax
issue specifically
well first of all there is a gift aid
application to cash a gift of cash
um
and of course as a high rate taxpayer
not only does a charity claim 25 but in
their tax return a high rate taxpayer
may be eligible to also claim 25 on the
gross donation now if they don't have a
record of it if they don't have receipts
it doesn't happen so I get people saying
that they're sort of not aware of it I
mean you'd think they would be really
sophisticated people who are
philanthropic and then they get annoyed
with their accountant why hasn't my
accountant told me about this and you
talked to the accountant and the
accountant says well it's all very
personal and a bit embarrassing and if
they've not given me any receipt I don't
think they've made any donations hence
the beauty of a donor rise fund like
prism because at the point of getting to
prison we give them one receipt whether
it's cash or shares or property One
summary receipt for their accountant so
that's that's Gift Aid in cash and then
there are really amazing tax breaks
around the gift of shares and property
where you get full income tax relief and
pay no capital gains tax
now it's they're very powerful actually
um there are also tax breaks around cash
offshore for a resident non-dom who
still earns income here which I won't go
into but it's also very powerful
legacies the government in 2012
introduced something called Legacy 10 if
you give 10 or more of your state to a
charity that balances tax at 36 instead
of 40 percent
so not only are donors and individuals
not aware of all of this
Nora their private client advises but
nor the Charities how many Charities put
on their
brochures marketing material
please gift AIDS sign here but they
don't say oh and you may also be
eligible to claim a further 25 on this
donation and explain to them the other
hold of the equation that's why there's
almost 750 million unclaimed so tax very
very you know it is a motivation it is
an incentive and by the way
again I'm trying to remember which year
it was where the government put a
ceiling on gift aid
to something like 50 000 then there was
a total up roll
all the news
um got misunderstood at all basically
said
well you know all these wealthy people
it's it's either tax evasion or or you
know they're just getting a tax break
and they shouldn't the reality is when
you give ten thousand pounds to a
charity you're giving ten thousand
pounds to a charity you could you could
go in non-holiday you know buy a car
with it but you've chosen to give it
away and yes there is a tax instead of
on top so total misunderstanding around
all of that what
the beauty of a donor rice fund it's a
it's an enabler it's trying to to
simplify giving encourage giving and
take away the worry the burdens and the
compliance the governance and educating
the background
unfortunately we have a charity
commission today that is
um
well quite frankly I'm not sure it's fit
for purpose I mean obviously it doesn't
have enough funding itself but actually
it doesn't offer guidance so what it's
it's terrified the charitable sector
it's terrified itself around
safeguarding issues and there have been
some bad safeguarding issues in the
sector but actually people are so
fearful to be a trustee
so
it's very hard for Charities projects to
set up it takes a commission sometimes
12 to 15 months to give someone
charitable status it then takes the
banking system another year to create a
bank account
so there are so many obstacles as well
um that that one needs to navigate in
in wanting to create a charity or or
wanting to give to a charity or
assessing a charity
um
and that you know I can talk further
about about why vehicles and strategists
are essential in the sector today to
just exist
or arrests
that's you've touched on tax
donor advice fund that prism operates
can you map in the collective fund as
well is that is that a different part of
your model how does the collective fund
yes uh approach support
um uh donation
thank you
um that's a really helpful question the
history behind that is in 2015
um we were referred one of the banks
referred a tragedy where someone's baby
had been killed and they quickly needed
to raise money from friends and family
um
they didn't there were no state to
create their own operational UK charity
and so we were able to allow people to
raise money tax effectively under prison
and then the world food program knocked
on our door in July 2016 and said we're
owned by the UN in Rome we're not a UK
entity but we need a vehicle to tax
effectively raise money in time for the
world rugby in October 2015 ITV was
sponsoring it government were matching
at Power per pound
and so prison became that vehicle and
then the refugee crisis in Europe broke
in 2015.
and lots of groups had started in just
giving Which you know is a very useful
platform but Josephine said we don't
really send 150 000 pounds to Calais and
do that due diligence and they found
their way to prison
and what we've learned over that period
is what we can do
what is a very robust application
process for a collective fund to come
into prison so you may have heard of
choose the love help refugees the
biggest Refugee group in Europe they
have a shop in SoHo
in London a shopping center in Manhattan
and they operate under prison they are
not their own charity so they do all the
work the fundraising
um decide who they gift to which
Partners they have
um they could respond very quickly to
Ukraine but we are their vehicle to
allow funds to be collected tax
effectively we do the overarching due
diligence compliance governance on
everything going out
um sometimes it also is very Swift
intermediate in covid when covet hit
because again of the length of time it
would take a group to create their own
charity we had as an example an amazing
Chef called Leonards who created
kitchens with compassion operated out of
Wembley Stadium out of the kitchen when
Billy was closed and made I believe 625
000 meals for the NHS and vulnerable in
that first year operating under prison
so we'd get
its own course saying we're delivering
tons of tomatoes to your office in town
and I'd say no you're not you're
delivering tomatoes to Wembley and we'll
pay the invoice
um so that enabled Leon to get going
he's since left us we incubated him he's
teamed up with the celix project so
that's a good story we can incubate and
sometimes
you know people do leave because they
have their own brand their own operation
um the collective funds are very public
very open because they're fundraising
they have uh their their own websites
but we are the overarching
um compliance and governance and enabler
um
so we'll help them navigate the rules
and regulations of the charity
commission and allow them just to get on
with the joy of running their program
and project
so you can you give advice you give
guidance and also you you have the
emergency uh response mechanisms for
many important um issues David uh Anna
touched on due diligence and the
importance of knowing that charitable
donations are effective how do you look
at that David how do you consider I'm
actually a trustee of um of a charity
the media trust and uh it's something
that we talk about a lot
um how do you ensure that the money you
do receive the donations you do receive
are used are used effectively and you
can report back yeah well you know one
of the key drivers of the the board that
we have in Scotland is you know looking
at due diligence and governance is is
critical you know and it's
we've always tried to you know make sure
that you know the balance of our Central
team and our programs team is fair and
so that you know we know that the
majority of investment goes directly on
taking delivering the programs
because actually what we've tried to do
is
to keep kind of costs down is looking at
saying well there's some organizations
um who might not be able to give you
cash donations but they can then look at
pro bono support and stuff like that so
I've tried to you know looking at or
travel we've got a partnership with
Scott rails or all our staff can travel
for free on trains and our playoffs to
events and stuff like that you know we
get some pro bono legal advice marketing
and stuff like that stuff that
traditionally Charities and Charities
might have to pay for managed to get
that and look in the Pro Bowl
Partnerships which just kind of means
that you know we know that when
investment comes in we can kind of get
the best kind of bang for our buck as
you would say and in terms of reporting
that you know we're working a strict you
know m e system using Salesforce and
using other kind of data collection to
then put together reports that we can
see you know in 2022 this is how many
players we supported this is a journey
of the players and here's some of the
kind of stats to come out with that and
how many players you know moved in
employment or didn't go back to prison
or improve their mental health and
well-being so we can start to show you
you know here's here's what the where
the investment went in in terms of and
how that um
what impact was created so so donors can
get you know regular updates in terms of
using Salesforce exactly you know what's
been done on the ground and David is
there a preferred way for wealthy
individuals to connect and and give
for you
I mean to be honest I've always kind of
left it up to them you know it's it's
there it's their investment you know
we're we're always just kind of grateful
for the support but it's
you know everyone's different some some
people just stay right here
you know I'd like to make a donation you
know just put it into your your core
course or whatever or another donor may
have an interest in you know a a
criminal justice you know in the same I
really want to create a program which
stops people from going back into prison
you know so then we can start the tailor
particular project which is already part
of the offer which so they will do that
or it could be an area you know it could
be someone's throw a particular part of
Scotland who's getting interest in you
know say Edinburgh for example so they
want that Their donation to make an
impact an Edinburgh so then we say okay
for 50 000 pounds this is what we're
going to do we're going to set up a you
know a women's only support project and
and then we can then say this is where
the money's going this is this is the
impact of it
um I mean I don't have a favorite as
such you know
literally in his Island was you know
it's it's very tight out there so you're
always kind of having to manage things
to make things work but I think for me
it's always about it's important that
we've got a relationship
with a with a family or the person who's
doing that so that we can you know bring
them closer to it just so because I
think a lot of things is everything's
built on trust you know those
relationships they're investing in use
an organization and you just want to
have that strong relationship to say
that
this is what's happening and then when
you've got that relationship is Aaron
knows sometimes you know events
put it apart you know things that
covered and stuff that we just didn't
you know see coming so then you had to
reach out to donors and went to say look
we're having to do this emergency
response whether it be mules and or
you know technology to get out to
players and support packages so by
having that relationship you can
actually do it this is what we're
proposing is that would that be okay for
you in in 19 it's it's fine I I often
say to donors
um
you know they want to assess charity
um and there are all sorts of different
Matrix metrics of doing that there's
something called the balance Harvest
school card but what doesn't that what
that's not taking into account is a
personal Journey or an emotional
connection and I often just say to Jonah
if you just trust the charity you know
yes there is reporting and and an
assessment but it but in the end if you
trust that charity they know best how to
utilize
the sun's actually a lot of the time
and I also
um say to donors sometimes
um
you can't
um
apply the same
it makes me very angry in the charitable
sector they'll say administrative
overheads need to be low because we want
all our money to be used only for
charitable purposes but you need to pay
your CEO you need to pay a fundraising
director you need to actually why
shouldn't you have proper paid and
decent overheads because actually then
you will have a better functioning
charitable entity
so that's another point you need to be
entrepreneurs
yeah and the thing is for something that
people think like China is it's just
like
is that getting the old-fashioned
you know it's just all volunteers who
are given the Euros at the time you know
but actually you know to be a charity
today you need to be entrepreneurial you
need to
you know be Innovative in terms of
because you know policies are changing
governments are changing everything and
we're in the middle trying to clean up
the mess often really technically or
entrepreneurial and find the right
skills you know like you know we were
talking about given away from me but one
of my favorite things I've given is when
people give me their time so when I look
when I started to create the older
trustees and committees for street
soccer
I'm trying to get the best skill sets
that I can't afford
you know whether it be General counsels
from Banks and you know what people in
really
High possessions get them in to be to
help Drive the Strategic direction of
the organization because always I've
always
I can get them on my on my board and
getting them working for me you know and
I think you know sometimes you need to
invest in the central course to actually
get a you know I kinda again
a couple of years down the line really
invested in the fundraising teams and
you know because if you don't do that
then you can't create change
but it's very aware of the time uh
YouTube which has been this has been a
superb superb conversation so thanks
very much so maybe we could just keep
these final couple of questions just
quite tight in terms of our answers
um a couple of a couple for you
um Anna
High net worth individual family office
approaches you
what are the first steps they take and
can you give us any examples of those
first steps for somebody who
doesn't know this territory well but
knows they want to make a difference it
really varies on the background of the
individual
um
there are occasionally
the ultimate underlying client of prison
that I don't meet because they have so
many advisors
they're they're sort of so in the
billionaire category
um generally we insist I insist I must
meet the underlying donor who really I
need to understand the motivation and
they need to understand prism in a
mechanism and that always helps
um
sometimes they continue to give whilst
they own tax and that it's almost
they're creating an endowment within
their donor Vice fund and Topping up
every year other people it could be an
IPO that's motivated them or an
inheritance that's suddenly motivated
them and some have again a very clear
idea it could be health education
children others have not a clue they
know they need to park the money
and they need some help in beginning the
journey now we're not strategists and
we'll refer them to a strategist in the
market to help begin that process
um our contracts also stipulate that
within three years of opening an account
at prison you need to make your first
distribution out because we have 250
million pounds of assets but we're not
here to collect assets we're here to get
money out into the sector so we do need
to motivate them
um so
it's also very important we do a lot of
lunch and loans with private Banks
private law firms to give them the
skills and knowledge and the language to
understand philanthropy to understand
the benefits of a general advice fund
and to really encourage the process and
understand the mechanism and
also very importantly
is is is back to the beginning of the
conversation about
about the responsibility to give to
giving your lifetime so I get questions
around legacies a lot I had one recently
someone said
um he's 70 white is younger wants to
give 100 million on death to six
Charities very quickly so I said I think
we could call that control beyond the
grave let's give them another 30 years
who knows what state the Charities will
be in then and if they are okay and they
absorb that kind of level of a donation
in one go probably unlikely we'd
probably want proposals on Grant
agreements and possibly a distribution
over three to five years with reporting
in between so
why doesn't he start in his lifetime
and by death he'll have a very good idea
of what he wants to support
um
so I don't always you know we don't
always persuade everyone to do the right
thing
um
but it's it's always an education on
many levels
and Anna before I come to you David to
tell us a bit about the future of
streets of street soccer Scotland are
things changing out of the next
generation of charitable givers how are
they changing the way they approach it
or will you still be struggling with
these issues in 10 20 years time
um
some of their objectives are different
so the beauty of a collective funded
prison it often is a hybrid sometimes
with a donor price fund and with the
Next Generation
So a family may have a foundation or
indeed
um there is no room for a trustee
from a second third or fourth generation
so they create their own quasi
Foundation under prism it could be
family and friends they eat put in money
and they may say we care about racial
Justice we care about the environment
well well there is no clear objective
within the May Family Foundation to
tackle issues that we want to tackle and
we're going to do it on our own and
actually through this mechanism we can
go out to the market seek applications
we then administer a quasi-ball meeting
we educate them in the process and the
whole objective can be changed over you
so it's a very flexible again we
entrepreneurial approach to giving and
and the other thing is that if
the really not involved at all it's
again a mechanism to try and motivate
them and make them think and take
responsibility
so
um
it's it's just a much more open method I
think of of giving
David let's leave
continuing the positive tone of Anna's
answer about the next generation of
people who want to be involved rather
than not at all involved I love that
phrase Anna
um David what next for street soccer
Scotland
just to carry on what we're doing you
know and when our strategy is always
more players involved more life changed
you know and looking at really
establishing ourselves more across
London in terms of you know more more
areas and more districts and more
sessions across sticking the London
programs we're coming at a time where
you know there's a lot of cutbacks and
governments and stuff like that and
there's what things are becoming a lot
tighter so really strengthening our
partnership model and working alongside
other Charities rather than everyone
kind of trying to do the same thing
let's bring you know because someone's
Journey starts here
but actually it does probably a number
of organizations who can play a part in
that person's journey to a sustainable
life so strengthening the the
partnership model
um and then yeah just trying to do the
right thing and build new relationships
David Jew MB and Anna Joss uh thank you
so much for your time what a fascinating
conversation uh that was rich with
advice uh and prompts and really an
appeal to not be that group of people
who are not at all involved let's
remember that phrase after this
fantastic conversation thank you Anna
and David so much for all your time uh
do join us again soon for another
journey into the future verse and in the
meantime for a different perspective on
money and life visit y dashree.com